here are 10 things wealthy people who
used to be poor have learned about money
and they're sharing it with you let's go
real quick let's let's it's almost like
a top 10 list people that used to be
poor but now they're wealthy here's what
they want to share with you about money
number one everything costs more when
you're poor buying things in bulk is
cheaper but when you're poor you're not
buying toothpaste multi-pack it's too
much up front all right so this is a
principle we've heard before that's why
people go to Costco and get ketchup
packets bottles of ketchup for the year
or they get deodorant for the year
toothpaste for the year because they're
gonna you know need it all year I think
Mark Cuban always talks about this
absolutely yeah big thing buy in bulk
buy in bulks that's number one you know
how the you know old people they say I
don't even buy green bananas right right
you know if you if you uh Paul I'm
looking at you if you need two packs of
deodorant you go ahead and Splurge treat
yourself oh yeah all right that's my God
um so that's number one everything costs
more on your poor because you're buying
single items rather than the multi-pack
the buying in bulk number two the
difference in quality between cheap crap
and the middle range is often far larger
than the difference between the Middle
range and the very expensive even though
the price Gap is about the same or more
all right let me break this down for you
if
um
if you're gonna buy a belt right and you
get three different options the cheap
shitty belt five bucks right middle
range decent belt 50 bucks and then you
get the most expensive belt 500 bucks
what they're saying is
split the difference by the one in the
middle because the cheap one is so janky
that it's you're gonna have to buy a
belt you know next month right and now
you're buying a new freaking belt and
the 500 one is so expensive that it's
not that much better than the 50 belt so
the point is this
split the difference go in the middle
don't you don't have to buy Gucci it
doesn't need to be a 500 belt you don't
have to go get a Louis Vuitton belt
shout out to our guy Bernardino
but you don't need to buy the five
dollar store belt right middle range
middle range what kind of belt are you
working with
um I
I'm wearing uh
reaction by Kenneth Cole belt shout out
to Kenneth
all right so split the difference don't
buy the cheap one you don't have to buy
the most expensive one you don't have to
buy the name brand belt you can just get
something decent that'll do the trick
and literally just keep your pants up
there it is all right number three that
we talked about this earlier
a bigger house means bigger headaches I
always ask friends of mine on a scale of
one to ten people that own homes how
much you love being a homeowner how much
you love being a homeowner and the
answers vary sometimes I'll get eight
nines tens and sometimes I'll get dude I
freaking it's I hate it too
I'm never gonna own a house again I'm
just gonna rent and just keep my
expenses low and move around and be
flexible I'm sick of the maintenance God
for you know the toilet the plumber the
refrigerator the air condition is so
much expensive the taxes okay it's not
that easy so I asked people this all the
time the answers vary but a bigger house
means bigger headaches you never have a
day in your life where you're like you
don't have to cut the lawn that there's
some issue the toilet overflowed it's
just not fun you gotta be really ready
for that you got to be ready you got to
be ready so a bigger house means bigger
headaches number four money can't buy
happiness but here's what it can buy it
can buy a sense of financial relief a
nice house us a car that won't blow a
gasket on the freeway a vacation abroad
a trip to the grocery store without
having to keep track of the total that's
awesome and a full tank of gas instead
of just 20 at a time and so on so you
work hard you make this money so you
don't have to look at the price tag for
everything but if you're smart you look
at the price tag make sure that you're
not spending too much but anyway money
can't buy happiness but I can buy a lot
of other stuff that's number four number
five
this is advice by the way that people
who used to be poor are giving after
being wealthy number five the real
currency is time the real currency is
time real wealth
means having the time to enjoy life
without having to worry about the money
we've heard this a million times we'll
say it again time is money our friend
Gerard talks about it's not income it's
hours of your life to earn the income
okay
if you work your ass off you're working
time time it's not necessarily the money
the real currency is time
number six the best thing that money
gives me is freedom to make choices the
best thing that you could say is I'm
good I don't need the job or hey we're
gonna need you to come and uh do this uh
thing for 500 bucks for the weekend and
we're gonna need to do this no I'm good
it gives you the ability to say no it's
a beautiful thing that's Freedom now if
you want to do and you want to make the
money say yes obviously but if you have
no money you have to say yes to
everything if you have money saved up
and you're good and you're chilling
someone offers you something you can say
no that's the difference that's what
they're talking about here with freedom
number seven the more money you have the
easier it is to make money it takes
money to make money it's kind of like
you had an analogy that you wanted to
use with it's kind of you're like listen
if you're going after a girl nobody
likes a thirsty dude right right or
anything in any way yeah like even in uh
at work like you don't want to be like
overly you know aggressive or like beg
you never want to beg for anything you
kind of want to just ease your way into
most things and then people kind of want
you to you know do more less is more I
think more so when you have more money
the easier it is to make money right
um
something that just to keep you know
keep that in your pocket right there
takes money to make money and when you
get the money you can invest in things
people always say all the time I wish I
had the 20 grand to invest in them I
wish I did well you could have had it if
you played your cards right all right
number eight I realize inflation keeps
taking my goals further away even though
I saved so much it seems like everything
inflates Out Of Reach just before my
life gets there
that's interesting someone who's wealthy
is worried about inflation what did
Warren Buffett say about inflation they
said the best protection about inflation
has nothing to do with your money per se
it has to do with your skill set be the
best at something remember when Warren
Buffett said this yeah the guaranteed
way to not get your to worry about
inflation is just be the best at
something people that are people that
are the best at something will never be
where they'll never have to worry about
inflation but also
I didn't learn about inflation in in
school you're circling back that's a
callback right I had no idea about
inflation in school so I think that
might be a good thing to teach people is
that if you just put the money in the
bank you could be losing listen uh
nobody's gone broke by having money in
the bank that's a good idea maybe you
lose one two percent five percent of
inflation you don't go broke that's
that's not about okay so you were too
busy learning about Hades and Greek
mythology in school inflation is the
thing it's real on average it's two
percent a year we get it right now it's
a little bit higher than usual maybe
double four or five percent nobody's
going broke because of inflation it is a
silent Thief that steals your money as
they say that's why you need to invest
because you know just having all your
money sitting there in a bank account it
is losing money over time but nobody
goes poor or broke because of inflation
but you want to beat inflation you do
um number nine
here it is you can have too much stuff
you can have too much of salary is not
wealth that's temporary money this
person goes on to say Diversified income
generating Investments are the
foundation of wealth if I could go back
to my 20s this is a rich guy talking
right now number nine
and spend even one tenth Less on stupid
crap instead invest in it I'd be better
off today Mo Money Mo Problems is for
people with no control over their
spending it's called a budget it's
called a game plan for your money it's
called understanding your income versus
your expenses and it just seems to be a
common theme Here save your money invest
your money don't spend it on stupid [ __ ]
and you're gonna be better off that's
number Nom and then last thing number 10
this actually of the people that are
that are these rich these rich people
that used to be poor we had a celebrity
appearance on this top 10 list and it
was none other than Kanye Kanye had some
wise words for the people he says having
money isn't everything but not having it
is okay having money isn't everything
but if you ain't got none
that's a problem that's gonna be an
issue that's a problem
I got 99 problems but money ain't one
these days that's Kanye anyway it's
always worse to be broke okay
anyway
those are the 10 things
that wealthy people learned about money
after
they went from being poor to being
wealthy
all we talk is money if you enjoyed that
short clip from the saucecast click here
to watch another click here to watch the
full episode or just stay bro
it's obviously